our chief medical correspondent that's
dr. Jon LaPook joins us now from his New
York City apartment to explain why there
has been such a spike in cases across
the u.s. John good morning to you you
know we all we've always been told that
the spike was coming that the numbers
are going to climb yet when you hear the
numbers it is so jarring how do you
explain this acceleration well you know
you heard David talk about the subways
this is a city where people are kind of
on top of each other very densely packed
and so the virus can spread more quickly
people have wondered about whether the
viruses on surfaces like in the subway
metal could have last for a few days and
then there's the issue of testing you
know we knew that there was a backlog of
testing so that specimens that would
drawn maybe days ago even a week ago I
suddenly be processed yesterday so we
have to get to the point where today's
numbers reflect what happened in the
last 24 hours and not what happened say
days ago well Jon New York's Governor
Andrew Cuomo has said to America look we
are your future what's happening here
will happen in your communities looking
at the numbers from where you sit do you
think that's accurate yeah you know
nobody knows it's an unpredictable virus
as many viruses are so I think we should
look at this and take it seriously
what's happening here maybe other places
aren't as densely packed maybe it's not
going to spread as quickly but it's a
virus to which none of us have any
pre-existing immunity and we can expect
that is going to happen similarly
elsewhere now I've heard you talk to a
researcher who's developing a blood test
for antibodies to show if people have
developed an immunity what are you
hearing about that was it why is this
important Gail this is the single most
thing that I'm talking about right now
in terms of something we can do
differently so Florian Kramer is a PhD
microbiologist at Mount Sinai and he has
developed already an antibody test to
see whether you have had the infection
remember the PCR test with the nasal
swab that's it you have it but we need
to know is there evidence that you had
it in the past why is that it so
important because we need to know are
there people out there who had it and
then perhaps our immune those are people
who we could send to the frontlines
potentially because they would be
presumably
now right now we're talking about this
war between you know do you spend all
the resources to fight the disease or to
help save the economy you can do both
and you have to do both and this could
be a way that we could really get there
and it's very very important we have to
ramp up he said it's no more difficult
than the usual measles mumps and rubella
test that you get you see millions of
them done every year it's just a matter
of will of getting through the
regulations putting money behind it but
I think this is the single most
important thing to do right this second
that we're maybe not doing yeah and I
can see why dr. Jon LaPook thank you
very much immunity raises the point yes
that most people recover from this more
than a hundred thousand people worldwide
have recovered thousands in this country
have recovered so there is hope and I
don't think we can say that enough that
if you get it it is really survivable
you just have to do the right thing
follow all the precautions yeah that's
right people need to be reminded of that
but it is scary Tony it's very scary no
doubt about it no doubt about it